welcome to the all digital ces set for
2021 i'm so excited
rich is over there look at you working
away oh i'm actually formatting the
stage computer so i can use it as my own
we're on set getting ready to host this
week it's going to be so much fun i look
forward to seeing you guys
all there and this is the set oh my god
it's so beautiful like i wish that i
could shoot all my youtube videos here
maybe maybe i just won't leave
welcome to my ces 2021 vlog
this vlog might look a little bit
different than previous years that's
because ces
is all digital this year and look here's
my host rich
what's up can you believe that we're
hosting again ces
when we host ah what was that it had to
be like eight years ago nine years ago
i'm guessing
we had a billboard it was so cool okay
we gotta go
we're doing rehearsals
[Music]
look at that that's serious right now
whoa we are
working ces ready this set is so
incredible like this is the coolest
thing i've ever seen
are you guys available for for vlogging
i just want to spin around and get this
whole set
so at my desk i have my yerba mate my
water
my empty cup my mask my surface duo
and my other surface devices there's a
lot of surfaces happening
surface hub okay so this
is the green room it's really weird
being on an actual set again because i
haven't been on a real production
in over a year so everything is so
different because
everybody is basically more than six
feet away and there's different
entrances and different ways that you
have to go so that you're not actually
passing by people another thing that's
really different about craft services is
they don't have that anymore because you
can't have
cross-contamination of food but this
look at this pancake breakfast quiche
breakfast
and instead of there being food actually
in here
well there is food in there but they're
all individually packaged
and of course there's never a shortage
of coffee okay we are heading
back onto the studio now
[Music]
day one of rehearsals is complete and
tomorrow we're starting very early again
but the next morning our call time is at
40. like i have to be camera ready by 1
40 a.m
so i'm going to bed at 6 00 p.m right
now to start prepping for the very early
call time
so good night
morning it is day two of ces
not technically even ces yet but we have
rehearsals and
i woke up at 3am because tomorrow we
have to get up at
actually i have to get up at midnight to
get ready for the actual show day so i
just
did about i guess a five about a five
mile run
uh i only planned on doing like two
miles and then
i got a little lost so i actually didn't
have a choice i
i had to keep going to to make it back
to my hotel uh i thought it was going to
be freezing out
but it was actually a really nice run so
time to get ready and uh
start this right this day
this is this is what we look like now
it's
just it's still shocking to me that this
is
the new normal this is it
another normal i had this delivered
from amazon prime now from whole foods
before i even got to the hotel
when i got here the guy was like we had
to check you in early because you had so
many packages here
that we didn't know what to do with them
so the urban was waiting for me when i
got here
[Music]
got all my microsoft goodies we are
ready
for rehearsals there's rich he already
got me on his
what's up camera are you vlogging i i'm
you know i'm gonna do a little behind
the scenes
yeah why not for kcla i think people
like to see the process
i think so because it is a very new and
interesting process that we're all
kind of going through like a production
in covid ces
the first ever digital one it's pretty
cool
and we're actually at microsoft filming
and shooting this at their studios
so i brought all the microsoft goodies
out and there's even microsoft coffee
cups
there's even a microsoft pen that i
don't have right now but there is one
and it has like a stylus on it at the
end
it's pretty exciting time to rehearse
third largest economy into a hub of
innovation
cta's gary shapiro recently spoke with
secretary oh
let's take a look let's take a look rich
let's take a look here do you want a
little more content there calling out
the french tech running the startup
scene j7
7. want to get the most out of your ces
experience of course you do
so to help you with that here are some
tips and tricks on how to make this show
all your own
check it out that's the short one we
will be going into the back with tag
board
[Music]
i'm gonna say i think we're further than
six feet apart i think so yeah
this is our cool little ces tracker here
so you can see all of the tweets that
pop up whenever anybody uses
ces 2021 look there's brian
and naomi so they're hosting after us
rich and i have the morning shift
and by morning we mean like as soon as
it hits a.m
we're up yeah very early it's maybe like
the midnight shift
it's so early
uh this is the surface hub and they
don't know it yet but it's coming home
with me i'm gonna bring it home
justine what's happening on the big
board there oh we have so much happening
it's really incredible because everybody
at home can participate by just tweeting
and using the hashtag ces2021
and rich and i are here in the studio
so the one challenge is once you have
your hair and makeup done and you put a
mask on
you basically mess it all up so this
face shield is pretty awesome jenna was
making fun of me because she said
if i go outside in the rain in this it's
basically just like a funnel and it's
just going to collect a bunch of rain
we're inside there's no rain like look
at this control setting over here we've
got
so much stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
mostly for justines but i'm still here
check out this behind the scenes shot
we're now
directing the vlog yeah we're ready
look at that whoa that is
we are cbs ready we are oh my gosh that
looks so amazing
incredible
[Music]
i just did an interview and right now
i might be on the screen in a second
there i am that's me
guys this studio is so cool it's like
how am i ever gonna go back to my normal
studio again
so that's the end of this video i'm so
excited for ces if you guys haven't
already registered i'll put a link in
the description if you guys want to
check it out for more information if you
do want to watch and participate it is a
registered event so you do have to
register to be able to watch all of the
live streams and all of the content
and some of you guys i posted a picture
of my lightsaber and you're like why
would you travel with lightsaber
well my friends jedis never
quit and
very soon i'm gonna be a jedi just not
yet i'm still practicing
[Music]